but let me give you another one the one
that's most obvious and I know many of
you already know this you've heard this
so I'm preaching to the choir but let's
go to Genesis 22 the story of Abraham
and Isaac what's the connection with
Abraham and Isaac and Jesus Christ
notice God tells Abraham to offer your
only son whom you love your only son
whom you love now what's interesting is
that in the New Testament in Hebrews
11:17 Isaac is called my
monog the only begotten son why is that
important in Hebrews 11:17 monog if you
want to show them brother so they can
see it Amen brother monogan is the term
that John uses of our Lord Jesus Christ
five times four times in the Gospel of
John one time in the epistle but first
let's look at Hebrews 11:17 what is
Isaac called he is the what of Abraham
by faith Abraham when he was tested
offered up Isaac and he who had received
the promise
offered up his only begotten son and the
Greek word is monagan that word is used
of our Lord Jesus as the monogan of God
let me give you the references Jesus is
the monogan of the Father John 1 verse4
write it down we're just going to look
at one or two of them you choose
whatever you want John
1:14 John 1 verse 18 John chapter 1
verse 18 John chapter 3:1 16 John
chapter 3:6 John chapter 3:18 I'm
repeating it more than once so you don't
okay so you guys don't miss it so John
31618 and then 1 John chapter 4 verse 9
1 John chapter 4:9 those five places the
Lord Jesus is called the father's
monogan right and if you want to just
bring up one of them and show them the
Greek so they could say Isaac is
Abraham's monag Jesus is God the
father's
manag Amen brother it is right here
that Greek word we just showed you look
at that right there in the red look in
the screen where I'm highlighting my
cursor you see the red the you don't
even need to know Greek to recognize the
very same letter the very same word
managan right here utilized right here
and the word became flesh and dwelt
among us and we beheld his glory the
glory as of the only begotten of the
father you got it so Jesus like Isaac is
the
of his father not only that remember
what God Said to Abraham take your son
whom you love in Mark 111 and Mark 9:7
and you can look at one of them if you
want brother Mark chapter 1:1 Mark
chapter 9:7 the father says to Jesus and
about Jesus you are my son whom I love
you are my beloved Son and W with whom I
am well pleased so are you making the
connection Jesus like Isaac is his
father's wellbeloved only begotten son
only begotten son of the Father the one
whom the father loves and
adores so that's the first connection
between Isaac and Jesus and their
relationship to their respective fathers
everyone got it because it's going to
get more deep now I know a lot of you
already know this ji and biblicist
Arthur and everyone else have heard this
but it's okay we're creatures are
petition when we hear something more
more and more it become second nature by
the grace of the Lord Jesus Christ Jesus
like Isaac is his father's beloved Jesus
like Isaac is the Father's only begotten
man other connections between the story
of Abraham and Isaac and God the father
and the Lord Jesus Christ on the cross
let's go back to Genesis 22 Now read
verses 3 to 4 for us brother here you
go so Abraham Rose early in the morning
and saddled his donkey and took two of
his young men with him and Isaac his son
and he split the wood for the burnt
offering and arose and went to the place
of God had told him then in the third
day Abraham lifted his eyes and saw the
place AAR off what day did he
arrive what day did he then on the third
day Abraham lifted his eyes and saw the
place ofar the light switch should go on
is it a coincidence that Abraham and
Isaac arrived at the very sight Mount
Moriah on the third day the very site
where Isaac would have to be killed as a
burnt offering to
God you guys see it Third Day
coincidence I think not now notice what
Abraham says that in some translations I
don't they don't capture it but it's in
the Hebrew and I don't know if this
translation captures it oh yeah it does
glory to God look at verse 5 genesis
22:5 here we
go and Abraham said to his young men
stay here with the donkey the lad and I
will go Yonder and worship and we will
come back to you now if you guys don't
read attentively and are not focusing
you're going to miss what you just read
Abraham says to his servants you stay
here the lad and I will go and worship
and we will come back to you the lad and
I will return and in the Hebrew it's
plural and you saw it in the translation
now question didn't Abraham know
he was going to kill Isaac so if he did
why is he saying the lad and I we
together will come back either Abraham
was lying or Abraham realized a more
profound truth either Abraham was lying
or Abraham realized a more profound
truth so Abraham's not lying right not
at at this juncture earlier he lied but
God had mercy on him the reason why
Abraham could say we will come back the
lad and I will come back is because
Abraham knew the promise of God in
Genesis 17 if you read Genesis 17 and
just for the sake of brevity because I
want to go into the darkness Genesis 17
we're going to read 19- 21 well let's
start you know what at 15 Genesis 17 15-
21 here we go that God said to Abraham
as for Sarai your wife you shall not
call her name Sarai but Sarah shall be
her name and I will bless her and also
give you a son by her then I will bless
her and she shall be a mother of Nations
king of people shall be from her then
Abraham fell on his face and laughed and
said in his heart shall a child be born
to a man who is 100 years old and shall
Sarah who was 90 years old bear a child
and Abraham said to God oh that Ishmael
might live before you then God said no
Sarah your wife shall bear you a son and
you shall call his name Isaac and I will
establish my Covenant for with him for
an Everlasting Covenant and with his
descendants after him brother that part
again emphasize that part of the
Covenant with him for an Everlasting
Covenant and with his descendants after
him with Isaac's descendants after him I
will make this Covenant forever now keep
going
amen here it is and as for Ishmael I
have heard you behold I have blessed him
and I will make him fruitful and will
multiply him exceedingly he shall beget
12 princes and I will make him a great
nation but my Covenant I will establish
with Isaac whom Sarah shall bear to you
at this set time next year so you caught
it now I know Arthur is excited he's
already going in ahead oh look guys he
carried the cross like Jesus Oh Arthur
calm down brother breathe Arthur I know
you need attention I will give you
attention I'll affirm you because I love
you young man logos but guys pay
attention to what you just read God
swore to Abraham my Covenant is with
Isaac and Isaac's descendants forever
but in Genesis 22 Isaac hadn't had any
descendants he didn't have any children
so now God is telling Abraham go ahead
kill your son but hold on God you're a
God who keeps faithfulness you're
Covenant making and keeping God you
proven yourself faithful to me because
you said I was going to have a son from
Sarah and you gave me a son against
impossible odds because you do not lie
you cannot lie and you've kept all your
promises and you promised this is the
child Isaac that you would number my
descendants through my descendants would
be numbered through him his descendants
would be their the Covenant but now
you're telling me to kill
him but he has no descendants so if he
dies that ends but you can't lie you
already swore it's him so then what's
going on here so then Abraham reason
with himself God is testing me that if I
am going
to show that I love God more than Isaac
and offer Isaac as sacrifice God will
reward my love for him that I love him
more than Isaac and the blessings that
he gives me by raising Isaac back from
the dead because God cannot lie he must
keep his promise that means Isaac must
have
offspring that means he must be able to
raise him back to life and cause him to
have Offspring to fulfill the promise
all of this that I'm giving you I didn't
make up all of this that I given you I
didn't make up I got it from Hebrews 11
let's go to Hebrews 111 17-19 Paul by
inspiration of the Holy Spirit reveals
the inner thoughts of Abraham what
Abraham was thinking because the spirit
made it known to him Hebrews 11:17 to9
by faith Abraham when he was tested
offered up Isaac and he who had received
the promises offered up his only
begotten son of whom it was said in
Isaac your seed Shall be Called
concluding that God was able to raise
him up even from the dead from which he
also received him in a figurative sense
so all of this psychology I didn't make
up Paul revealed it to us because the
Holy Spirit made it known to Paul the
Holy Spirit revealed to Paul this is
what Abraham was reasoning since God
cannot lie and he swore Isaac's seed
would be The Heirs of the Covenant that
means that though Isaac will die God is
Almighty over creation over life and
death he will then raise Isaac back to
life in order to keep his word to me and
fulfill the promise that Isaac would
have descendants to be the air of the
Covenant did you catch it that Insight
given to you by the spirit through Paul
in Hebrews 11 you caught it and so then
Paul says and in a sense he did receive
him back from the dead what do you mean
in a sense because as far as Abraham was
concerned Isaac was as good as dead so
when God stopped him it's as if he
received him back from the dead
figuratively speaking now put on your
thinking caps Isaac was raised from the
dead figuratively speaking what day
Genesis 224 told us on the third day
Abraham's only begotten son
the son whom he loves his beloved Son
was raised back to life from the dead
figuratively on the third
day sink in so Abraham and Isaac a
picture of the Father and Jesus Christ
his beloved Son now there's a difference
folks whereas
Abraham was prevented from going through
with the sacrifice the
father
didn't prevent the knife from being
plunged into a son figuratively speaking
but he took it all the way so that his
son actually physically
died showing that the Father's Love For
Us is greater than Abraham's love for
God and that the Father outdid Abraham
because Abraham though willing to offer
his son didn't have to see a son die
whereas the father saw his son slain by
the hands of Lawless men of Sinners go
back to Genesis 22 now let's continue as
we go back to Genesis 22 let's bring out
some more nuggets now we read five let's
read Genesis
2226 here we go so Abraham took the W
wood of the burnt offering and laid it
on Isaac his son and he took the fire in
his hand and a knife and the two of them
went together okay notice six again one
more time y here we go Abraham took the
wood of the burnt offering and laid it
on Isaac his and he took the fire in his
hand and a knife and the two of them
went together so Isaac carried the wood
that would be the instrument of his
execution compare that to John
19:17 John
19:17 here we go and he bearing his
cross went out to a place called The
called a place of a skull which is
called in Hebrew golgatha did you catch
it like Isaac jesus carried the wood the
instrument of his
execution like Isaac did now let's go
back to Genesis 22 let's read 7
to8 here we go but Isaac spoke to
Abraham his father and said my father
and he said here I am my son then he
said look the fire in the wood but where
is the Lamb for a burnt offering and
Abraham said my son God will provide for
himself the lamb for a burnt
offering went together keep that in mind
God is going to provide a lamb of
sacrifice whereas in Genesis 2213 we're
going to skip notice what God provided
he didn't give a lamb what did he give
then Abraham lifted his eyeses and
looked and there behind him was a ram
caught in a Thicket by its horns so
Abraham went and took the RAM and
offered it up for a burnt offering
instead of his son now understand a ram
is not a lamb I don't care how you spin
it a ram is not a lamb not at all yep so
a lamb wasn't given a ram was but now
catch it it was caught in a thorn bush
the Ram's horns was caught in a thorn
bush now our lord Jesus had a crown of
thorns placed on his
head you see the connection between the
RAM and our Lord and a ram has horns
right
brother that is that's correct brother
okay now why is that significant a ram
has horns this Ram has horns caught in a
thorn bush a Thicket is a thorn bush
just like our lord Jesus had a crown of
thorns placed on his head and what was
his crime his crime was that he claimed
to be the king of the Jews right King of
the Jews now let's go to Revelation
17:12 to see what a horn represents
the 10 horns which he saw are 10 Kings
who have received no kingdoms as yet but
they receive Authority for one hour as
kings with the
Beast now what is a horn it's a king who
has a kingdom who has Authority a ram
has two horns a horn represents a king
with a kingdom who has Sovereign
authority Jesus was killed because he
claimed to be the king of the Jews but
he's also the king of the Gentiles two
horns king of Jews and King of the
Nations and he had a crown of thorn
placed on his head and he was slain for
claiming to be a
king I'm just waiting for it to sink in
I don't want to go too
fast okay this is a ton a ton of meat
and potatoes really really Hardy
theological teaching brother I mean if
if the people aren't being blown away I
don't know I don't know what could blow
him away that's right so that's why I
wanted to sink in guys two horns why
King of the Jews and King of the Nations
the world is divided into two Jews and
Gentiles and Jesus is the king of the
Jews and the
Gentiles and that Ram has two
horns thorn bush caught in a Thicket
like the king of Israel who's the king
of the Nations had a crown of thorns
placed on his head and like the ram was
killed in the place of Isaac he died in
Isaac place so Isaac is spared Jesus
dies in our place so we can be spared
but Still
Still the Lamb wasn't provided so that's
read Genesis
22:14 here we go and Abraham call the
name of the place the Lord will provide
as it is said to this day in the Mount
of the Lord it shall be provided okay
now notice Abraham Knew by revelation of
the holy spirit this mountain is
significant because on this mountain
Jehovah Gyra yahovah Jehovah will
provide where was this mountain read
Genesis 22:2
again then he said take now your son
your only son Isaac whom you love and go
to the land of Mariah and offer him
there as a burnt offering on one of the
mountains of which I shall tell you okay
pay attention this mountain is in
morah go to 2 Chronicles 3:1 a mountain
in Moriah and Abraham by Revelation Holy
Spirit knows that this mountain is
significant for the Future 2 Chronicles
3 ver1 here we go now Solomon began to
build the house of the Lord at Jerusalem
on Mount Mariah where the Lord had
appeared to his father David at the
place that David had prepared on the
threshing floor of oron the jebusite I'm
confused where did Solomon build the
temple would be a house of sacrifice
offering burnt offering sin offering
guilt offering
where the house of the Lord at Jerusalem
on Mount
Moriah you gotta be kidding me dude you
serious so God revealed to Moses this
place will I'm sorry to Abraham this
will be a sign place because here in the
future a temple will be built where
burnt offerings sin offerings guilt
offerings will be offered up to the Lord
all of which we read in Hebrews are a
shadow of
Jesus and the M Abraham said God will
provide the lamb for himself well go to
John 1:29 and then read 36 John 1 29 and
36 here we go the next day John saw
Jesus coming toward him and said Behold
the Lamb of God who temps away the sin
of the
world 36
again no and looking at Jesus as he
walked he said Behold the Lamb of God
2,000 years later the Lamb of God shows
up in the flesh to take away our
sin so where does the Old Testament say
Messiah would die for our sins and rise
again in the story of Abraham and Isaac